also ich würde sagen das ja es
machen hätte müssen ich glaube
dass ganz klar war für leute die über
solche dinge von außen objektiv drauf
gucken ob solche dinge drauf guckt man
sich das angucken das ganz klar war dass
er zu viel passiert ist der springer
verlag zieht sie darauf zurück dass ja
gar nicht soviel wusste viele der
aussagen und compliance bericht und
anonymität zusicherung gegeben wurden
und sie nur eine zusammenfassung von
vorschuss bekommen haben am ende ist das
natürlich springers problemfrei spiels
ist von springer beauftragt die hatten
dafür sorgen müssen dass diese
compliance untersuchen so durchgeführt
wird dass man da auch konsequenzen
ziehen kann ich glaube auch dass man aus
dem was bei verstoß aufgelaufen ist
konsequenzen müssen ganz klar frau am
thema eine kurze passage aus dem spiegel
damit manchmal versteht worum es geht es
geht um das machtgefälle zwischen jungen
frauen und deutschlands lange zeit
mächtigsten boulevard journalisten im
sex der zwar einvernehmlich war aber
augenscheinlich mit beruflichen vor und
nachteilen verbunden und um drängende
nachrichten mitten in der nacht was
heißt das dass meine kolleginnen und
kollegen die dieses ursprünglich im
frühjahr schon berichtet hatten haben
das zusammengefasst als zustände wie an
einem mittelalterlichen königshof also
dass da reichelt als chefredakteur als
mächtigster mann einer der mächtigsten
männer der medienbranche überhaupt seine
macht nutzen konnte um beziehungen
affären einzugehen mit frauen vor allem
jungen frauen die teilweise auch nur
befristet da waren die vielleicht auch
eine praktikantin oder eine volontärin
waren die sich noch bewähren mussten die
also auf besondere weise auch abhängig
waren von der gunst des chefredakteurs
und dass da eben ein system diese
abhängigkeiten entstand und das wurde in
der untersuchung die händler zitiert hat
von der anwaltskanzlei freshfields auch
aufgearbeitet
aber offenbar war diese ganze
untersuchung mehr darauf gerichtet
entlastung herbei zu führen als
belastung also von springer seite nicht
von der kanzlei seite so dass am ende im
prinzip man gesagt hat dann macht doch
so eine tolle performance als
bild-chefredakteur dann sehen wir mal
darüber hinweg was er so privat mit den
frauen macht das ist doch alles
einvernehmlich gewesen hat der döpfner
ja heute auch in einem verteidigungs
video gesagt da ging es nie um sexismus
da ging es sozusagen nie um sexuelle
belästigung schauen wir auch über sein
leiden sehr interessant ja ein problem
damit zu sagen und eben dieses thema
machtmissbrauch wurde offensichtlich
nicht als problem angesehen browsers ich
habe die tat beobachtet haben gerade
gelegt und ich habe sie auch angekündigt
wollen sie sagt ich kenne dieses system
dieses jahr vier jahre für springer
gearbeitet und auch darüber hinaus immer
sehr gute kontakt zum haus gepflegt oder
auch private kontakte und ich habe es
gibt ein grund warum ich als autorin auf
der frankfurter buchmesse diese heute
fluchtartig verlassen habe und mir
überlegt habe ich muss für dieses thema
da sehe ich auch hochschwanger 5 stunden
ins auto gesetzt habe weil ich glaube
ich hätte ist unerträglich gefunden wenn
in dieser runde schon wieder über dieser
wichtigen runde oder auch sonst wie
jetzt bislang in der öffentlichkeit
keine der betroffenen frauen zu wort
kommt keine der betroffenen sondern
immer nur über sie geredet wird und
julia klöckner sagte auch in der
frankfurter rundschau heute im interview
das hauptmotiv diese frauen nicht zu
sprechen also nicht auszupacken und
interviews zu geben er ist eben angst
und das ist das ist für mich völlig
inakzeptabel und ich hatte das gefühl
dass uns dieser studie bleibt die die so
weit ging so wurden sie gar zitiert oder
ihre kollegin frau löffler wohliger
zitiert hat rapper dass die frauen die
stadt verlassen haben bevor sie ihre
aussage gemacht haben bevor wir springer
mit unseren recherchen konfrontiert
haben weil natürlich springer lange zeit
gar nicht wusste dass wir da zu
recherchieren wir schauen ja genau mit
wem sprechen wir wie wie können wir die
recherche so gestalten dass wir
möglichst lange in ruhe im hintergrund
gespräche führen können aber klar in dem
an dem moment das war der vortragende
montag also vergangene woche montag als
wir quasi detaillierten fragebogen
sowohl an julian reichelt als auch an
die konzerne pressestelle geschickter
mutter mathias döpfner war klar die
wissen bescheid oder ab dann haben sie
die chance druck ausüben haben sie die
chance die flächen zu verhindern haben
die chance die quellen einzuschüchtern
und da haben einige frauen gesagt ich
verlasse über die stadt
hajo schumacher der sehr lange auch im
journalismus ist viele medienhäuser
kennt für sie irgendetwas neu an diesen
enthüllungen jetzt oder etwas von dem
sie sagen das system ist das kenne ich
das systemische finde ich neu also die
hamburger medienszene ist ja sehr eigen
hier sind viele große verlagshäuser und
die waren damals war bild in hamburg
also dazu sagen geringer war der spiegel
die zeit gruner und jahr und der stern
die goldenen zeiten sind ein bisschen
vorbei aber das war die monarchie also
das waren das waren königshäuser ihren
hamburger verleger waren hier ganz große
nummer und
das war alles sehr hierarchisch
konstruiert und diese verlage haben
jeder für sich weil er die kann das aus
dem spiegel bestätigen wo ich vor über
20 an gearbeitet habt da hat sich die
kultur grundlegend verändert ich glaube
bei derzeit genauso und bei springer
offenbar nicht so und ich glaube jeder
verlag in deutschland hat seine eigene
kultur
mein haus die funke mediengruppe ich
glaube eine der ganz wenigen verlage die
ihre frau an der spitze hat julia becker
und die hätte glaube ich schon im märz
anders reagiert eine frau an der spitze
des verlages hätte vermutlich nach
diesem ersten spiegel-artikel anders
reagiert und nicht gesagt ja weil er so
viele tolle verdienste hat darf im amt
bleiben was eine komische begründung ist
um eine ganz anderes über wobei man
sagen muss im vorstand von axel springer
sitzt auch eine frau die auch bei dieser
untersuchung beteiligt war frau kasper
die jetzt auch nicht gerade sich
wahnsinnig engagiert hat um diesen
frauen zu helfen oder sie liebe dieses
direkt bei herrn döpfner quad mit am
tisch und wurde auch mit dieser
untersuchung ja auch sie genau also als
gerade fragen ist nicht so justine
vorstand prozent zu und auch bei diesem
einen punkt mit stoff hinweisen es muss
nicht unbedingt eine frau sein die ein
problem die diese probleme gestellt
sondern sollte das problem sein aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass wenn sie eine frau
an der spitze eines verlages haben ist
da eine andere kultur gibt das volk
angreifen
anders entschieden und beim verleger
eben wiederum sieht man ja auch das
argument heißt wo ich will einem
wettbewerber nicht schaden also ein
vorgeschobenes ökonom komisches argument
wir haben es hier aber mit ganz anderen
verletzungen oder grenze übertretungen
kann das kann man so schlecht gegen
einander aufwies ist eine ganz billige
methode bevor wir gleich mal zur frau
rosa alles kommt er treibt da können sie
an erklären was war der grund der
auslöser
der dazu geführt hat dass sie im märz
als das ganze thema abgeräumt schien
angefangen haben nochmal genauer
hinzugucken ja also was man natürlich
sagen kann ist dass viele viele leute
die mit diesem komplex opfern zu tun
hatten egal ob als beobachter betroffene
andere menschen die damit zu tun hatten
damit nicht mit einverstanden waren so
wie wir jetzt sagen wie konnte man das
so entscheiden wie konnte man da nur so
eine kleine verwarnung aussprechen wie
konnte man da nichts tun und das ist
natürlich damals schon viele gedacht und
vor allem leute die sich da noch besser
mit auskennen ich meine von außen wirkte
das schon komisch und wohin muss es noch
die komische und absurder und und
enttäuscht gewirkt haben und dann ist
natürlich klar dass die gerüchte die
vorher schon rum gegen die geschichten
die vorstellung haben ja auch schon nat
mir glaube ich auch schon im interview
gesagt ende vergangenen jahres das erste
mal überlegt damit einzusteigen und als
dann klar wurde dieses komplett fand
trotz des artikels trotz der
öffentlichkeit führt zu nichts er wurde
unter druck natürlich größer und juliane
löffler ist seit jahren einer der
wenigen reporterin in deutschland die zu
mieten recherchiert die auch schon
vorher starke geschichten gemacht hat
und natürlich wenden sich dann leute an
jemanden wie juliane um da zu sagen
willst du da nicht mal reingucken und
dann haben uns dafür was hat sie was hat
sie herausgefunden was sie raus kopieren
hat den details um die es jetzt geht was
ihr die konkreten vor die natürlich alle
seit montag bei spiegel.de nachlesen
aber man kann glaube ich schon sagen
dass es definitiv
systemische beziehung gegeben hat in
ihrer beziehung das schülern reichelt
sexuelle beziehung gehabt hat mit frauen
die in einem ganz krassen machtgefälle
zu ihm standen und wo sich berufliches
und privates so vermischt hat dass die
frauen große probleme hatten mit diesem
machtgefälle umzugehen unter druck waren
und da auch drunter gelitten haben und
da sprechen wir gleichauf sicher noch
drüber an dass sie quasi eigentlich auch
oft keinen ausweg in dem sinne hatten
weil was macht man dann wenn der
chefredakteur der über alles bestimmt
mit einer berufsanfängerin anfängt
anzubandeln anzubaggern wie wir gegen
das wo sich das vorstellen
man geht am schreibtisch vorbei und sagt
das ist ganz toll was du heute der
konferenz gesagt hast also wenn zum
beispiel eine junge kollegin irgendwie
in der konferenz etwas geistreiches
gesagt hat oder so und er wurde auf sie
aufmerksam
dann kommt er bei ihr vorbei und dann
muss man sich vorstände kommt nicht
irgendwer da kommt wirklich der die
nummer eins der chefredakteur der
stärkste typ im ganzen haus kauft man
sagt so toll gemacht und ich glaube du
hast eine grosse zukunft vor dir also so
klappt jetzt nicht aber es wurde so
langsam immer mehr ein mentoren
verhältnis offenbar entwickelt immer
wieder und das dann gab es in essen
zusammen und dann gab es sozusagen
beratung und coaching dann wurde es
persönlich hat und vielleicht auch
private sachen erzählt und irgendwann
ging das dann so fließend über eine
affäre und manchmal ging es zu einer
beförderung manchmal wurde aber auch die
person dann irgendwie wieder fallen
gelassen was er dann auch eben
verwirrung verzweiflung angst irgendwie
ausgelöst hat auch immer das gefühl ich
muss jetzt weiter mitmachen ich muss an
die menschen ihren es kann ja nicht sein
wenn er jetzt gegen mich ist wenn der
sich über mich ärgert was passiert dann
mit mir was wird dann aus mir und es
waren eben leute die hatte ja auch der
kollege schon gesagt eben die die angst
hatten um ihre existenz die vielleicht
auch berufseinsteiger waren die keine
anderen erfahrungen anderen
arbeitsfeldern hatten wo sie vielleicht
auch normal behandelt worden wären oder
oder anders beurteilt worden wären eben
nicht nur nach ihrem aussehen oder also
ob sie jetzt geil oder fax oder was auch
immer da für labels für sie erfuhren sie
untersuchen im spiegel auch geschrieben
es gibt nur die fächer belegt
das heißt das ja ob sie es wert sind
rangenommen zu werden das ist eben die
kategorie die da offenbar sich also nach
denen leute bewertet worden sei ist wenn
sie das hören das muster ist unbekannt
wie muss man sich das vorstellen
ja also erstmal das [ __ ] gebildet die
das wort auch ein hollywood kriterium
nach dem auch in hollywood noch
heutzutage und auch in der deutschen
filmbranche schauspielerin gecastet
werden also das ist jetzt auch ein
großes strukturelles
es war eben die rede davon dass herr
reichelt eben machtstrukturen ausgenutzt
hatte und mit personen angebandelt hat
oder affären hatte die einen schon dem
er in eine extreme macht gefällt sich zu
ihm extrem macht gefährlich dann und es
ist vor zehn jahren hieß das dann
dienstag also das hat sich nichts aber
auch gar nichts verändert in zehn jahren
und das ist wirklich ein riesen
strukturelles problem auf dass springer
jetzt immer noch nicht reagiert hat weil
ihn keiner presseerklärung auch jetzt
heute von herrn dörfler kein wort keine
entschuldigung gegenüber den betroffenen
frauen keine einlassung dass sich die
firmenkultur in eine moderne auch
menschlichere unternehmenskultur
verändern kann also die betroffenen
frauen die ich
einige kenne ich auch die erleben genau
das was ich in meinen 20 also in meinen
zwanziger jahren sozusagen dort selber
erlebt habe und dass das war das war
furchtbar beklemmend die junge frau wie
war das bei ihnen können sie das mal
schülern ja sie sagten gerade ein ganzes
ist es ist immer so so so so seltsam
wenn dann auch im fernsehen oder den
medien wenn über diese fälle berichtet
wird aber eben immer über diese frauen
gesprochen wird nicht mit diesen frauen
gesprochen wird ist aber denkbar schwer
natürlich jemanden dazu zu bringen
öffentlich diese geschichte zu erzählen
und ich kann das ehrlich gesagt auch gut
nachvollziehen wie war es bei ihnen
naja ich kann sagen dass ich damals die
ein bewerbungsgespräch hatte bzw ich
warte sehr ernste sehr seriöse absichten
journalistin zu werden bis heute und
auch zu sein und ich hatte auch eine
mappe mit artikel mitgebracht das war
nie ein thema also wenn man es böse
gesprochen sagt ich wurde für mein
aussehen eingestellt ich habe natürlich
trotzdem versucht es war eine bewerbung
wo war diese bewerbung ich war bei
springe vier jahre
der tz und habe aber auch frei für bild
andere medienhäuser und gearbeitet und
war auch sehr sehr lange freie bei
springer bis ich irgendwann redakteurin
wurde das heißt sie kommen damit ihrer
bewerbungsmappe sie haben artikel die
sie selbst geschrieben haben sie haben
texte dabei von dem sie sagen da sind
gute texte auf die bin ich stolz gestand
er absolut das war das war nie ein thema
aber übrigens auch nicht in anderen
medienhäusern also ich hatte ich hab das
mehrfach erlebt dass niemand meine texte
angeguckt hat und wie gesagt man hat
sich auch dabei ist dabei gedacht und
habe man hat ja auch irgendwie thema
oder eine richtung in die man gehen
möchte aber dass das hat er so gar nicht
stattgefunden es ging eigentlich es gab
immer diese
unangenehm ist beklemmend das
arbeitsverhältnis auch weil man ständig
sms bekommen hat oder e-mails oder auch
einfach von sunbeam vom vorgesetzten von
kollegen von vorgesetzten ob verheiratet
oder nicht das war so ongoing stream und
damit ist man irgendwie entweder klar
gekommen oder man konnte auch wieder
gehen also das war einfach dass das war
irgendwie galt das als normalität und
das war auch keine normalität niemand
irgendjemandem ich habe damals noch
parallel studiert erklären konnte dass
jeder hätte gesagt du bist du dann geh
doch bitte daraus aber man hatte auch
irgendwie die die hoffnung dass man da
fuß fassen kann und dass man da
irgendwie auch was gutes draus macht und
ehrlich gesagt hatte man auch keine lust
solche leute irgendwie das letzte wort
zu geben weil dann heißt das auch ganz
schnell ach ja aber die die texte von
der ware nicht gut oder die hat es
ähnlich gebracht also wann wurde da sehr
sehr schnell dann auch wie man das
heutzutage ja auch wieder sieht
abgestempelt und es sind auch extrem
viele
durch diesen apparat gespült worden wenn
man das mal so salopp sagen kann und es
gab wirklich extrem viele auch schon
damals so dieses diese gutsherren
mentalität zum beispiel dass ich mit
einem der stellvertretenden
chefredakteure der sagte freitags okay
was babys gehen wir essen also wer wie
es übertrieben aber es klang so für mich
und ich war 25 war völlig überfordert
mit der situation
aber man wollte sich halt zeigen mit
junge kollegin und sonst das hat er
regelmäßig und mit wechselnden kolja mal
so mal so aber ich habe das auch alles
sehr selbstkritisch ich habe dann vor
vier jahren ein buch veröffentliche
sexuell verfügbar und habe das auch sehr
selbstkritisch beleuchtet also auch
warum ich damit gegangen bin und warum
ich das auch lange zeit
ja auch mitgetragen habe dieses system
weil da bin ich wirklich durchaus wie
gesagt selbst kritisch weil
das ist
das hilft niemandem und das hilft
niemand anderem und ich finde es gibt
auch sehr viele ausgeschiedene weibliche
führungskräfte bei springer die viel
besser hier in meiner stelle sitzen
finden wir die noch mehr wissen als ich
und die es nicht tun und deswegen
empfinde ich eine tiefe notwendigkeiten
das hier zu tun ich bin jetzt ganz
woanders in meinem leben aber diese zeit
hat mich extrem geprägt und prägt bis
heute meine bücher und ist auch einfach
wie man sieht immer noch das thema der
stunde
erst hatte schumacher damit als gut ein
buch geschrieben hast hab ich ja fast
zeitgleich praktisch aus der anderen
perspektive zum männer buch geschrieben
männer spagat und ich weiß noch wie
waren dem ausstoß glaube eine rezension
über ein buch geschrieben ich habe das
gelesen das war ganz interessant so von
der anderen seite einfach mal zu
reflektieren
wie wurde das wahrgenommen ich war ja
mal versehen der mediengeschichte aber
ich war mal zwei jahre chefredakteur
eine einer lifestyle illustrierten und
welche max max gerade wieder aufgelegt
als one shot tolles produkt hat
riesenspaß gemacht ich saß wirklich
letzte woche mit einer alten kollegen
die ich eingestellt hätte hat er hat
diese aktuelle theodor wolff preis
trägerin
hat sich bei uns in der küche wir hatten
gerade im podcast gemacht über ihren
preis und ihre ihre türkischen wurzeln
und also was sind siege sagte hajo was
ich dir seit 20 jahren nicht gesagt habe
aber du warst ganz schön ist noch damals
und ich dachte das sei so lustig oder
irgendwie so kumpelhaft gemeint aber sie
meinte dass leider ziemlich ernst und
sie meinte auch nicht nur mich sondern
eher ein klima also ich bin ich um
gottes willen also ich will mich wieder
mit julian reichelt verbrüdern noch ich
möchte aus der verantwortung nehmen aber
sie sagte mir so ein paar beispiele
konferenz 10 ja wenn eine frau
überwiegend männer als führungspersonal
eine frau sagte irgendwas die jungs
wollten die augen und dann kam so die
üblichen sprüche
irgendwas mit hormonen oder so also es
war jetzt nicht dieser dieser
machtmissbrauch wie wir ihn hier
geschildert sehen aber dieses gefälle
dieses top down dieses heiraten lassen
bei auch dieses nicht augenhöhe haben
das war teil der medienkultur damals und
mir war das nicht klar ich bin nur von
männern sozialisiert worden ich bin nur
in männlich geprägten situation
sportredakteur klar war wirklich wenig
frauen unterwegs für mich war das an
sich selbstverständlich und dieses augen
öffnen auch durch dein buch also einfach
mal dieses reflektieren ja das war
scheiße wie du damals warst und die
andern das gespräch und da bin ich total
bei melanie ahmann als erstes mal müssen
wir männer kapieren dass das nicht in
ordnung ist und dafür brauchen wir auch
frauen die uns das sagen und dann kann
man überhaupt erst mal über dieses
gespräch anfangen zu reflektieren was
war da wie machen wir es besser man kann
sich übrigens auch entschuldigen auch so
ein punkt aber
das ist ein prozess ich will damit man
überhaupt nicht er sich erschöpft ja und
der nächste schritt wäre er dann in
dieser idealen welt dass man auch mit
den männern bei denen man dieses
verhalten beobachtet spricht absolut
weil das problem ist doch jetzt dass
dieses thema sexismus ist ein
augenrollen thema bei dem man dann denkt
oh gott jetzt kommt dann der betriebsrat
und die frauenbeauftragte und was weiß
ich und irgendwie dann stehe ich auf dem
tribunal nur weil ich einen blöden
spruch gemacht habe oder so und
eigentlich viel hilfreicher sinnvoller
fruchtbarer wenn man so will wäre es
doch wenn zum beispiel nicht nur immer
die frauen die sind die sich über etwas
beschweren sondern wenn halt kollegen
männer die das ein bestimmtes verhalten
beobachten dass die ihn überhaupt erst
mal auffällt das ist vielleicht nicht
okay und dass die dann keine ahnung
welchen umfeld männer so was machen beim
bier oder in der teeküche oder
es war oder was weiß ich sagen sag mal
in dieser spruch vorhin das war glaube
ich eine nummer zu viel oder kannst du
doch nicht oder und das ist hat ja offen
sich das virus hat mittlerweile das ist
glaube ich sogar echte lange wurde sowie
tage nach jerusalem oder als sei das
normal ja absolut doch wenn ich das
sagen darf all das ist mir gerade so
aufgefallen weil bei dieser schilderung
diese ich glaube was jetzt auch für die
frauen bei die in diesem springer fall
so schlimm ist oder aber auch bei allen
frauen die in dieser situation sich
befinden diese scham warum habe ich das
eigentlich mit mir machen lassen warum
bin ich warum habe ich das mitgemacht
und das ist ja auch das was man jetzt
überall hört man ja die wurden doch
teilweise befördert was wollen die denn
eigentlich oder was auch der verleger in
seiner videobotschaft gesagt hat gleich
gesagt hat so da ging es ja nie um
gewalt oder belästigung oder so dass
noch alle mitglieder das war doch
irgendwie kein das war doch kein problem
wenn man so alles einvernehmen lägen
allerdings auch charme der männer
unterstützt das nicht es gibt es wäre
schön aber sozusagen diese ist dass man
ich finde es gut dass das jetzt endlich
mal der blick weg gelenkt wird von
diesem warum hat die frau dagegen nichts
gemacht sondern erst mal warum hat der
mann das gemacht warum wurde es ihm
durch ja und warum sie nicht noch mal
machen durchgehend das genau wird
möglicherweise auch klar wenn man diese
entlassungen hört auch des
vorstandsvorsitzenden mathias döpfner
sie sagten das glaube ich gerade keine
großartige empathie erkennbar oder
männlich einmal war es glaube ich keine
entschuldigung erkennen war in dem sinne
hat möglicherweise auch juristische
gründe ich will das überhaupt nicht
werten aber so klang das gestern gehört
mal kurz rein
was alles was denken sie wenn sie das
hören was passiert da wird ja was
umgedreht also der der mögliche
mutmaßliche täter zum opfer gemacht
also ich sehe jetzt zum zweiten mal
nochmal und
also man aber da weiß man gar nicht mehr
richtig was man sagen soll weil das ist
offenbar also die schlüsse die
die herr döpfner aus dieser causa zieht
sind sind so prozess falsch also dass da
kann man eigentlich wie gesagt ich sie
merken mir fehlen die worte weil eine
toxische unternehmenskultur oder oder
diese einlassung der frauen oder diese
darauf bestehen dass es einvernehmliche
beziehung waren
ist in solchen
hierarchischen autoritären systemen und
machtgefälle gar nicht möglich weil wie
gesagt und wenn die frauen parallel auch
noch sagen und er davon wird das
interview von julian löffler bekannt
sein das hauptmotiv dieser frauen angst
ist nicht darüber zu sprechen
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich eben da
helfen können wir zu dieser aussage
kommt sei und dieses narrativ dahinter
steht eine gruppe von männern genau die
das eigentlich alle machen also wieder
dieses raunen so soll das hat sowas
verschwörungs der sonneninsel aus den
beleidigten ex-frauen die irgendwie
jetzt sauer sind das sind nicht mehr
dass julian sie nicht mehr will und ist
und die mitte und den typen die
irgendwie den weg haben wollen und
deswegen angreifen also dass letztlich
eine verschwörungstheorie
total in dieses weltbild des gesamten
konzerns also letztendlich wenn man die
bild zeitung als person auf einem
psychologen couch legen würde dann hätte
man sich auch nicht stellung ja aber
dann hätte man doch also wenn die
bildende person wäre dann wäre sie ein
bisschen größenwahnsinnig ein bisschen
rassistisch sehr sehr wütend sehr sehr
unklar in ihren haltungen das frauenbild
in der bild leserbild relativ selten
manchmal gibt sich um zu gucken sonst
aber das frauenbild ist da immer noch
relativ ich sag mal antiquiert also da
ist sehr viel
verfügbar und hier bikini und trallala
so wenn das das weltbild ist um alles
was wenn wir das wenn wir uns daran
erinnern was zu tun hat gender sternchen
was ist das für ein quatsch und so also
da hatte man schon den eindruck die sind
sehr der zeit hinterher bewegen sich in
so ein viertel der gesellschaft braucht
das alles vor den augen nochmals ist
glaube ich dass das was mich am meisten
schockiert an dem statement ist einfach
die aussage
gegenüber seinen männlichen kollegen
wenn wir diesen binären weltbild bleiben
sind sie wieder geschlechts bild bleiben
ist eigentlich jungs ihr habt nichts zu
befürchten
und liebe kolleginnen liebe frauen wir
hören nicht zu
ich finde zwei punkte total spannendes
einer ist es natürlich komplett
irrelevant wer aus welchem interesse
hier welche informationen weitergebracht
hat es geht darum was sind die fakten zu
die fakten haben wir jetzt mit dem
spiegel zusammen berichtet die waren
aber auch in grundzügen springer bekannt
weil sie da mehr anwaltskanzlei wochen
daran gesetzt haben und 50 interviews
geführt haben natürlich hätten die im
märz mit den fakten sagen müssen das war
machtmissbrauch jetzt ähnliche und das
zweite ist was ich wichtig finde das
natürlich in diese videobotschaft die
frauen überhaupt keine rolle spielen und
das ist überhaupt nicht darum geht wie
geht's jetzt den frauen was es mit den
los das ist einfach wie sie wie sie
sagen das war wahnsinnig schwierig mit
diesen mit diesen frauen zu sprechen und
die kollegin juliane löffler aber auch
die beiden kolleginnen damit daran die
recherchierten kathrin landsmann marcus
engert der monatelang gearbeitet um
dieses vertrauen zu gewinnen der mit
mehr als zwei dutzend personen
gesprochen mit mit weiteren quellen
nicht nur mit betroffenen und diese
aussagen abzusichern es gibt hunderte
dokumente
nachrichten von reichelt die all das
belegen und in diesem statement also das
ist so weit weg von dem was eigentlich
belegt und berichtet ist dass ich da
echt wie sie verschlucken mustert das
gewinnen haben wir nochmal einen zweiten
teil rein da geht es sozusagen meine art
chronologie das spielt auch diese
anwaltskanzlei an der rolle und die
frage die sie gerade an getippt haben
sozusagen die frage was wussten die
entscheidenden leute bei springer
tatsächlich oder was wussten sie
möglicherweise nicht auch das sehr
interessant ist
so faszinierend ist an diesem video ist
ich meine das ist der chef des
mächtigsten
medienkonzerns in deutschland deren
eigenen fernsehsender hat und er nimmt
ein video auf wie als würde irgendwie
seiner oma zum geburtstag gratulieren
oder also so mit dem und ist also das
finde das ist jetzt ein seiten aspekt
gebe ich zu aber die formate ich habe
mir die haben wir nicht zu werden das
ist leicht gesagt hab ich das auch so
gesagt völlig in ordnung die anderen das
inhalt es ist eben nicht den ort bestens
das sei genau das statement loses zeigt
wie ernst er die sache nimmt das werde
ich ihm aber nicht aufgrund des videos
soll also der alles deutlich strenger
dies hätte dann hört die gesamte
belegschaft also nicht kommen oder
zeiten versammelt und das sind tausende
und er spricht so zu sagen es ist
mehrfach in der vergangenheit passiert
erträgt sondern zugenommen trägt seine
augen terroristen signieren um sich
absolut und es ist es ist einfach es
zeigt eine sehr deutliche sprache wie
hoch er das thema aufhängt und wie sehr
er vielleicht auch interesse daran hat
dass eine menschlichere moderne
unternehmenskultur einzuführen
der bremer noch mal kurz darauf
zurückkommen was springer wusste was sie
hätten machen können sie es ja immer
wieder darauf zurück ja die frauen an
sich ja an mit zusichern lassen wir
wussten nicht wer es war wir konnten
julian nicht damit konfrontieren zuerst
uns der gedanke vielleicht warum haben
sie das getan weil sie wahnsinnige angst
haben der zweite natürlich ist es ja
nicht so dass julian auch schön juliane
löffler im interview schon gesagt wenn
ich einen zettel in den briefkasten
geworfen und gesagt jan hat ihm etwas
böses gemacht und wieder nach hause
gefahren sondern dem er stundenlang für
interviews gesessen bei der kanzlei mehr
detailliert berichtet auch sich es gibt
ja genug leute die man dazu befragen
kann dann und sagen kann ja das stimmt
so das habe ich miterlebt hat wirklich
das und haben wir alles beobachtet die
haben teilweise dokumente angeboten und
zur verfügung gestellt
dass das das dass die die belegen können
das ist ja auch im spiegel alles
berichtet worden und wenn man dann sagt
wir konnten nichts machen das ist
natürlich eine sehr einfache ausrede sie
sie sagen da hatte man sich eben an
dieses verhalten gewöhnt ihre kollegin
löffler hat vorgestern in den
tagesthemen folgendes gesagt wir haben
mit vielen leuten gesprochen personen
gesprochen die selbst sehr prominent
sind und selbst sehr viel macht haben
ich habe aber auch da immer wieder
erlebt dass leute angst haben sich zu
äußern weil die bild als medienmarke und
fassbar starkes und dass sie mit ihrer
reputation massiv darunter leiden werden
wenn sie teil einer solchen recherche
werden das heißt worin bestand die
konkrete angst
dass ich meine jeder kennt kennt die die
aussagen kennt was bild macht mit leuten
wenn wir den leuten nicht passen und
dann werden sie vernichtet es gibt bild
mit dem aufzug hoch und runter bild
fährt kampagnen unter julian reichelt
hat sich das verstärkt wenn da jemand
nicht nicht passt dann gibt es da ja
auch keine grenzen also ich kann das
komplett nachvollziehen dass heute vor
der bildung vor der person nur dann
reiche dankt hatten